hey guys it's justine and this is ro we
just shot a video on her channel a nice
little celebration for the valentine's
day season
oh yeah that'd be really fun to react to
some of our old videos
oh so we have i've never done this
have i i don't know i have we reacted to
our videos did we do this video already
no we might have no this is a really
good chance
i've never done this with you well this
is exciting because today is the day and
we have
69 videos this playlist are you
making that number up 34 35
videos this is an ongoing playlist that
i've been keeping for the past couple of
years
listen here's the question do you
remember what our first video was that
we did
i was just gonna ask you how do you
think we've made our relationship
last over the years you know just a real
love talk for valentine's day and then
you hit me with a question of what's our
first video and i don't have a clue
but let me tell you ro what has kept us
together
starbucks true i called you this yes
i've only been to starbucks three times
since this pandemic started really
this was my third time i got a little
breakfast sandwich and it was so good i
missed it so much
aren't they good they're delicious yeah
oh definitely you know starbucks kept us
together our love for
dogs and then i think i just honestly
dig you
did you as well look at this we're
sharing the love here
on valentine's day which is actually
well we're posting this before about it
it's coming up
the season our first video is we're okay
wait were we
baking no no yes we were trying
starbucks it was the first starbucks
challenge at your house
do you were shut up yes that was our
first video
together yes look i wear a little star
wars are you like your pink little
sweater guys you're so cute you're so
cute look at you little star wars oh my
gosh we've hugged that was our first
song
oh my gosh oh my god filming on a round
table that table was so
low it was like awkwardly low i'm a
genius i figured out that frappuccinos
are cold
2016. he was probably not even a year
old yet team
now he's so like chill now our second
video you actually came to my house
and we baked together we did okay the
decorating challenge
for you guys that don't know like row
does so much really like great prep for
her videos and knows everything that
she's going to be doing
i was like i don't know we're going to
do something just come on over we're
going to do something so
is this the one with the big the big
spatula it's a huge fat
you're the coolest kitchen all those
lights um you have the coolest kitchen
so yeah this is like i think was this
right around wouldn't your book come out
oh my gosh yeah like six years ago so
that was this was
the first teen what is my necklace like
you know when you think you're looking
really cute and then you look back and
you're like
what is on my body i think it's cute
look at our cakes oh man
wow i was like so worried i was like
rose coming over we're gonna make a cake
and this is what i have for her
look at this oh this week this was a
vlog yeah yeah we did two vlogged about
it we did part one and then we had so
much fun we did a second one i think
they were like seasonal drinks okay i'm
vlogging in 2016 in 60 frames a second
and i'm disgusted with myself
why what's 60 frames a second it's a
tragedy
is what it is ro what do you mean oh
there's cookie
who was on it is 60 frames a second fast
or slow
it's fast like you don't right this is
this looks great
remember we unboxed snapchat spectacles
this was my first unboxing
ever i had never done an unboxing before
and you were showing me these spectacles
and this is the very first this is the
very first one
after this we went somewhere i think we
went to lindsay's show we went to an
event i think officially the first video
you guys did together was the music
video
mike just informed us that the perfect
together music video was
this was so beautifully shot like it's
incredible
thank you i love doing this i should
actually do this more i had so much fun
you guys making this music video we
built this entire set
on the youtube sound stage their largest
sound stage is a custom
choreographed waltz it's like a unique
wall
cute you are so cute look at you
there's jimmy oh my god captain sparkles
there's jordan
justin how come it feels like i've known
you for ten years okay but the first
video when i
actually found out about you was which
one from the call of duty cake that you
made
oh yes what year was that we're gonna
find out
that was when
but i was too nervous because she was
like just
doing everything on the internet and i
was just starting so i was too nervous
to ask her to come bake with me so i
made a cake that i thought she would
love
and then i kind of just like i freaked
out everybody was tweeting it to me i go
oh my gosh
who's this cool girl that's making cool
cakes look at me
this is the best look everybody wanted
you to make black ops 2 cake
wow i literally had this army helmet i
went to this army surplus store and they
had like all these cool things and i was
like oh cool put all this stuff in here
and then i look stupid the fact that
this is like eight years ago
and like what you have created you see
this red mixing bowl
yeah for years i got this ole at walmart
and there was a crack in it for years
but i did not have the money i did not
have the budget to buy a new bowl
so i literally would scotch tape it
every time
i used it maybe you can spot it but this
is so cool because it's like i mean this
is something that you're so passionate
about look at that and like
right there like that's amazing you just
knew this is what you're gonna do
because like a lot of people they think
that like youtube happens like overnight
yeah they think that it's easy and they
think that everybody is just given
everything like it's not
it's a lot of hard work yeah so like you
should be so proud of everything that
you've done
and you guys should be so proud because
this is
this is crazy look you started from a
cracked bowl and now you're here this is
so
embarrassing it's like a four dollar
bowl from walmart and i was like well
there's my budget for the year
look at the cake it's so cool and girl
that was made on a budget so
that is a budget cake and i think it
looks pretty good for what we had
i'm impressed remember we tried fun
valentine's day candy
today well here was our last one 2017.
what we had big gummies then too you
know video game ones
those are cool i really liked hemlings
oh this was a tattoo
lollipop and card did you know that do
you know what you're talking about
look at it look at it look at it you're
like this is great i put two
oh my gosh you're double using it it's
not that good of a night idea oh guys
this isn't your old place
i'm going to the lego i thought you'd be
proud we made the little holder out of
legos
this is where i learned about these
chocolate melting pots
i was lawn dewpox what is this it
changed everything in my baking well
this is when i was doing a lot of little
braids
this is so cute we're making our little
lego marshmallows
look at us with our nails dude your
nails look
awesome by the way i love that
color that polish that's really pretty
remember we went to hawaii
that was so oh man check out my drone
shot just okay
your drone is freaking amazing this
might have been the part where it
actually
it took off yeah yeah i had to find the
drone
on a map so we did this crazy hike
across this river let's see what our
most popular is
oh my gosh it's the cake decorating one
is it really yes
12 million whoa that's a lot really
why are you guys watching that you know
what this tells me
we just need to do a talk show yeah look
at us okay i'll have to come up with a
name or something
we can throw some nape if justine and i
were gonna have a talk show
would you guys please tell me in the
comments down below what should be the
name of it because i don't know what to
do
we'll figure it out oh we're trying that
little food kit
that was the little toy food yummies oh
we were trying some dog products
this is such a sweet video clearly
neither one of them wanted to be here
no they were like i want treats and to
go sleep or play
oh matt he is like fatty cheers because
his allergies were so bad
oh she's such a little loaf i miss that
little nugget but i have to say
blueberry muffin is like coming into her
own
i would say she's my next little angel
baby look at us matching look at our
green tops i know it's almost like we
planned it we didn't we didn't
we didn't plan this either today no we
just show up and we end up dressing like
each other
you think it's like when like couples
accidentally start dressing like each
other and then friends
over the years we just do the same thing
kitchen gadgets
you have done so many of those on your
channel so many
we haven't done one in a while we need
because we you know because everything
kind of shut down and i
on my way here today got a cover test i
was like bro i'll be turning back around
going home
if it's if it's positive yep we're
here yeah we good
so much because you love grilled cheese
sandwiches yeah so i thought let's try
this grilled cheese maker
i can't even remember if it was good oh
it's hard to say
there's a company that clumps them and
they make the little clone of them and
send them to you
so this sits in my house and like it
scares me all the time because i think
it's maddie and then i know my sister
has the dog and i'm like
maddie what are you doing here you're
not maddie literally looks like it
really does so i know this is uh mike's
favorite video
the time we carved our faces into
potatoes
can i say that after we did this a few
other of my friends did this
really so you started a trend because
this was not a trend this is absolutely
the dumbest thing
i was like what are we doing today
justine brings over
these potatoes and she was like we're
going to decorate them to look like each
other
we're at 1.8 million views right now oh
my gosh
decorating the potatoes
wait how did why do they look kind of
good so i'm surprised they look great
for
potato art you know so we each made
a potato look at these
this is so stupid so mine is so
ugly glued on
what else have i made you do i made you
react to the new iphones
oh my gosh this is the iphone 11 you
always teach me new things that i had no
idea existed
oh this was my favorite when we
decorated yes
the christmas tree every year around the
holidays
i watch this video it's so
funny it's so silly we are decorating
a christmas tree blindfolded somehow
justine has looped me
into the lights yep and i didn't realize
that i was
attached to the light i'm lassoed in
there
i love it so much i think this was one
of the best ideas you've ever come up
with
for the holidays because i remember it
too as being one of my favorite memories
i seriously
watch this like every year around the
holidays i'm like oh it's so good
i love to watch our holiday stuff at the
holidays because i've never done
what's it called vlogmas i've never done
it so i like watching our videos because
they're really
fun remember this we built this hot
wheels set
oh we had like a hundreds of them going
they were going so
they actually move a lot faster than i
actually thought
do you remember i was so i was like
trying to find like kid sizes sweaters
for you because i need them
what the heck have we done wow wow
i hate that i think i actually threw
those in the trash after i left
this is one of your kitchen gadgets i
think this is the one
do you remember we tried to make mac and
cheese so this was supposed to be like a
whole video
and you ended up having to make an
entire video off of the mac and cheese
because we had so many problems
yeah yeah we had so many years
yes
there's a ton more videos if you guys
want to check it out i'll put a link in
the description to a playlist that has
both of the collab videos from both of
our channels on it
there's so many like start taking notes
like find your favorites tweet them to
us and let us know which ones you guys
like the most
maybe we'll do some more yes please
it'll be so fun make sure you go check
out ro's channel we did a fun
valentine's day video there
and you've got so many fun videos that
you've been doing recently like really
cool lifestyle ones we're in your new
place
i love it make sure you subscribe check
it out and we will see you guys in the
next video
[Music]
bye